I am become a big box office destroyer
of Records but how did a three-hour
biopic about a scientist become a
surprise box office smash here's the
secret to oppenheimer's explosive
success let's start with the elephant in
the room Oppenheimer was pitted against
the Margot Robbie LED Barbie from day
one in the lead up to the film the
competition between these two
diametrically opposite stories was
obvious everywhere so much so that the
experience was quickly dubbed
barberheimer by Avid fans from both
camps Mattel's movie helmed by the
immensely talented Greta Gerwig was
guaranteed to attract a massive
Millennial following along with their
own offspring in the name of nostalgia
this is the best day ever at the same
time Oppenheimer had a disturbingly
Fatal Attraction for countless viewers
due to the many other reasons included
on this list this led to one of the
strangest standoffs that we've seen at
the box office in ages two heavyweight
movies by well-known directors each able
to hang with the best of them and bring
their own fan-based theaters at the same
time they went toe-to-toe on opening
night and in many cases moviegoers
embrace the friendly competition by
booking back-to-back showings the result
was a surge of marketing momentum that
benefited both films even if Oppenheimer
came in a distant second at the box
office there's no question that both
movies were better off for the mutual
energy the mainstream marketing for
Oppenheimer consisted of solid
well-executed traditional Studio
marketing slashy posters and cryptic
teasers the film's release on the same
weekend as Barbie created a natural
competition that helped both exceed
expectations but there's another factor
that cannot be overlooked when
considering what contributed to both
film success the means you guys ever
think about dying the barberheimer
concept was more than a conversation it
also manifested in visual form via an
endless string of fan-made crossover art
these featured various iterations of
Barbie and oppenheim in the same picture
often the somber orange overtones
associated with the latter would blend
with the Cheery optimism of the former
throughout this organic fan-driven
marketing campaign it also created one
of the greatest Grassroots marketing
movements of all time it helped
propagate the double header concept that
many embraced on opening weekend and the
jarring combination of the film's
promotional materials ensured that
everyone was aware that these two movies
were coming out another Barbie related
factor that contributed to the success
of Oppenheimer is the fact that the
biopic provided a welcome counterweight
to the pink heavy Barbie experience
taking place in most locations one
theater over the Margot Robbie film may
have been a huge hit with a wide
audience but it didn't speak to everyone
the simultaneous release of Oppenheimer
meant anyone interested in a more
sobering and philosophical cinematic
experience could skip the over-the-top
positivity of Barbie the two films cater
to very different audiences and memes
aside Oppenheimer provided a welcome
alternative for those who weren't in the
mood for all that pink
it's a well-known fact that Christopher
Nolan movies attract an avid fan base
we're not saying all of his movies are
Classics but the renowned Brit has a
sensational track record since breaking
through with his sophomore feature film
Memento Nolan has been on a quarter of a
century hot streak his style isn't for
everyone but there's no doubt that it's
distinct exciting and always leaves fans
wanting more the continued popularity of
his films means that a new Nolan movie
is an event that his fans won't want to
miss Nolan's producing power was always
going to help Oppenheimer achieve Great
Heights all on its own but it certainly
helped to have some A-list support along
the way the movie features a host of
Hollywood's top brass with a well-known
face popping up every few scenes leading
the line is the ever watchable Killian
Murphy the Irish actor is known for his
standout performances in the likes of 28
Days Later sunshine and more recently
the hit series peaky blinders Murphy is
also no stranger to Nolan cinematic
world he played scarecrow and Batman
Begins and Robert Fisher in Inception
however Oppenheimer is his first leading
role in a Nolan film and Murphy doesn't
disappoint backing up Murphy's portrayal
of Oppenheimer is a smorgasbord of
recognizable faces Emily Blunt features
opposite Murphy as Kitty oppenheimer's
wife Florence Pugh also shows up in the
role of oppenheimer's girlfriend and
then mistress Gene tatlock the film also
includes Robert Downey Jr as political
antagonist Louis straws in one of his
first major film roles since leaving the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Matt Damon
plays the key role of military liaison
Leslie Groves and Kenneth Branagh shows
up for a few scenes as Danish physicist
Niels Bohr and the list goes on and on
from there marketing for Oppenheimer was
another factor that helped bring the
crowds in troves the movie's striking
visuals filtered through to the film's
promotional material the captivating
image of the title character in front of
his horrifying creation was one of the
most memorable images around in the
weeks leading up to the release date the
trailers helped too each clip shifted
between a dramatic narrative featuring
many of the film's well-known actors and
close-up sequences of explosions and
billowing Fireballs the disconcerting
compilation said it all without really
saying anything added to the alluring
confusion of the trailers were countless
other questions why was this Nolan's
first R-rated film in over two decades
why did he choose a biopic why is it so
long what cinematic trickery would the
director unleash in the movie the result
of months of this kind of advertising
was that it created a frenzy of
anticipation and curiosity fans knew
they had a solid idea of what was to
come and yet they had no idea what the
experience would be like in real time
like it or not 2023 has been the year of
so-called artificial intelligence from
real life programs like chat GPT to the
fanciful sci-fi Concepts and shows like
Apple TV plus Foundation AI is in the
spotlight and it even finds a voice in
Oppenheimer though an indirect one
according to director Christopher Nolan
himself Oppenheimer is a cautionary tale
for those engaged in pioneering modern
technological Concepts speaking to the
press in Paris the director connected
modern AI to the first atomic tests
saying artificial intelligence
researchers refer to the present moment
as an Oppenheimer moment a bit later in
the interview he added that those
working on AI now can draw important
lessons regarding their ethical
responsibility from oppenheimer's story
from there he clarified that there isn't
a direct takeaway being taught here
saying but I don't think it offers any
easy answers it is is a cautionary tale
it shows the dangers when a director
tells the world their film is a
terrifying cautionary Tale on an
apocalyptic scale you can bet your
bottom dollar it's going to draw a crowd
you can also bet Nolan's words in the
context of the film's disturbingly
open-ended finale will continue to ring
in viewers ears as they process the
emotionally traumatizing three-hour
ordeal the development of the atomic
bomb has a direct through line to
Everyday Life in 2023 and this isn't
even hypothetical we still live and
breathe in a nuclear age since the 1940s
nuclear arsenals have proliferated
across the globe and regularly factor
into public policy making the war in
Ukraine has stoked fresh fears about
nuclear weapons being used again and
panic seemingly spreads faster in this
day and age the 24-hour news cycle plays
a big part and so-called nuclear anxiety
is highest among those who spend more
time on social media a recent study has
shown the fact that there is such a
direct connection between the subject
matter of Oppenheimer and Life as we
know it is a clear draw for many viewers
even Nolan referred to the film as kind
of a horror movie filled with impossible
ethical dilemmas most Millennials and
all gen zers don't have any memories of
what it was like to live in the cold war
let alone the horrifying final days of
the second world war the chance to know
more about the man that kick-started the
nuclear age was an easy selling point
Barbie may have beaten Oppenheimer in
the sheer volume of tickets sold but
Nola's film triumphed on the biggest of
the big screens according to deadline
Oppenheimer raked in 35 million dollars
on its opening weekend via a select 740
iMac screens around the world that's 20
of the film's opening weekend box office
total a record ratio to date IMAX CEO
Rich gelfond addressed the incredible
results telling deadline Oppenheimer is
an undeniable demonstration of a
paradigm shift in moviegoing with IMAX
taking a commanding share of global box
office as audiences show a clear
preference for experiences that
transcend the ordinary in cinema Nolan
added my Max for me is a portal into a
level of immersion that you can't get
from other formats this pursuit of a
bigger and better cinematic setting
doesn't just translate to a greater
experience it also directly impacts the
numbers IMAX is more expensive on a per
ticket basis which means the same number
of C seats will lead to a greater
opening weekend Financial total in other
words Oppenheimer didn't have to attract
as many viewers to achieve the same
level of success since one in five
members of its audience paid a premium
for a seat in the case of Oppenheimer
the IMAX Factor goes beyond the price of
tickets it also has to do with the
desire to see some eye-popping visuals
complete with seat shaking sound effects
the attraction here is obvious the
film's Magnificent visual set pieces the
Trinity test in particular were major
draws from the first day marketing
started the fact that the movie features
a true explosion instead of a CGI one
also caught the attention of many Avid
moviegoers as did the fact that it was
filmed and played in select locations on
a 70 millimeter large format film IMAX
CEO Rich gelfond also dug into the
reason that pushed many viewers to
choose IMAX over traditional theater
viewing telling deadline as he has done
throughout his career Christopher Nolan
pushed the boundaries of IMAX technology
to deliver Unforgettable storytelling
with Oppenheimer and audiences are
responding in numbers we've not seen in
our 50-year history Nolan's willingness
to play the part of the pioneer and push
the limits of even the best cinematic
technology was a major selling point of
the experience the man already has a
track record of powerful visual elements
from the mind-bending mental Landscapes
of inception to the time warping space
Adventures of interstellar while
Oppenheimer didn't head into the
scientifically unknown its Atomic
setting provided ample fodder for some
of the greatest shots in the history of
Cinema and Nolan didn't disappoint the
entertainment world has had a superhero
overload problem for a while now and
barberheimer's opening weekend was a
damning recognition of that fact the
world was buzzing with excitement For an
upcoming pair of films featuring
precisely zero superheroes one was a
childhood toy adaptation and the other
was a biopic about a scientist what does
that mean going forward there has been a
consistent drop-off when it comes to
interest in Marvel and DC films as of
late the MCU movie Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania opened to 106 million
dollars domestically and failed to pass
the half billion Mark in total a
definite disappointment for a Marvel
picture
ouch meanwhile DC's Standalone feature
The Flash only hit 55 million dollars on
its domestic opening weekend and was
considered a dismal failure and don't
forget all of this is graded on a curve
superhero movies have been in a steady
state of decline in recent months in
comparison Oppenheimer handily beat the
opening weekend of The Flash and was
quickly catching up to quantumania
before the Bell told midnight on Monday
morning the box office success of
Nolan's latest offering shows that
audiences are still there and they just
might be starting to move on from
superhero movies